thanks for coming first throat of
business I'm sure you all heard that
twigs got pulled out the river this
morning they ain't no secret he and
Carvell grew up in Hood together
listen up Carvel about to say some words
[Music]
okay you know what
no not you look at them tears and think
that's funny because it takes a big man
to cry in front of his crew
go ahead car man
y'all know twig was my boy back in the
day we used to pretend the sofa cushions
with a fort
mm-hmm and we used to pretend at the
floor with mop-up okay you know what
though
hey nothing funny about that
of course this man is crying because he
and twigs was kids together okay you're
Millie's best friends forever
go ahead Carvell we used to play Care
Bear twig then I would spend the good
part of an afternoon trying to figure
out with Care Bear we just start
laughing cuz ya'll know you think the
funny
Carvell over here blubbering and talk
about Care Bear
but you know what it's but you some
manly tears okay just some manly ass
tears right there to look in there go
ahead Carvell man that was weird a
sneeze
right dude goddamn can a brother get
some claritin up in here
go ahead Carvell wigged always fancied
himself share bear always Oh thought of
myself and more of a funshine bear okay
you a funshine bear man I'm sorry that
that is I let go throw some crack
you